For Saw 6, a new director was brought onto the
series, and just like all of his predecessors,
Kevin Greuetert was a first time director,
though he did have experience with the franchise
having edited movies one through five. On his
title card, there’s some flashing effect going
on with the letters VI, highlighting the
roman numerals for this sixth installment.
There would be a lot of sixes that come up in this
film, like the fact that John’s instructions for
his ex-wife come in six envelopes; the inclusion
of six new traps; the “dog pit”, which was a
group of six insurance policy inspectors
who were all tested in the Carousel Trap,
and according to IMDb “The soundtrack "Zepp Six",
has a length of six minutes, and is played in the
background of the final six minute climax scene
before the credits roll.” Hard to say if that last
one is really intentional. But even with all the
sixes found in this movie, there’s an even more
important seven, and I’m not talking about Mr.
Feldman’s line when he gives the box to Jill.
“Ms. Tuck, what's in the box?”
“What’s in the box?”
I’m talking about a new seven, that hints to
the audience that the next sequel will be the
last of this saga, so stick around to the end
of this video if you want to hear about it.
Welcome to Things You Missed. I think Saw 6
is probably the most underrated movie in the
franchise. We get to see Jigsaw explore some new
territory, as the film makes a statement about
the health insurance system in the United States.
It was a topic of discussion in 2009 when Saw 6
came out just five months before The Affordable
Care Act, also known as Obamacare was passed,
and it may be an even bigger topic of discussion
as I’m recording this video in the year 2020,
as the world is going through biggest
global health threat of the past century.
Many of the traps in Saw 6 are symbolic of
the position that health care providers have
to take when considering coverage for a client.
There are also some disturbing Things You may
have missed outside of that. But I’m not
allowed to say them until after the logo.
[THINGS YOU MISSED]
That doesn’t actually make sense, cause I
already said some Things You Missed at the
beginning of the video, but our opening trap
features a couple of malicious money lenders,
who planned to repossess more than
their payees could ever pay back.
And honestly, this one never made sense to me,
because it’s completely unfair. The rules state
that whoever offers the most flesh onto this
scale will be the one to survive, and the woman,
Simone, has considerably less flesh to give.
She’s at a disadvantage because she’s healthy.
As per Jigsaw’s motto, she cherished her life
more, and yet, she’s being punished for it?
Still, if I was in the trap, I
would have put all my clothes
on the scale first. It’s not like
this movie isn’t already rated R.
We are then introduced to the Umbrella
Health company. I think this is less of
a Resident Evil homage and more of a reference
to the purpose of an umbrella, to cover you,
just as an insurance company offers coverage.
But this company is very particular about who
they’re willing to cover, and has a team of
policy inspectors checking up on people to
make sure they are at a low risk to actually
get sick. They sit around a circular table in
the middle of the office whose shape resembles
the Carousel Trap that they would eventually be
placed on. This team is referred to as “The Dog
Pit” and the top dog is Dave, who has an award
on his desk that says “Terminator of the Month.”
This is obviously in reference to the termination
of insurance plans, but looking back on it with
more context gives it a darker meaning where it
seems to be about the termination of human life.
“Terminator strikes again!”
The boss, William Easton, works with his lawyer
on a deposition about a man named Harold Abbott,
the father of the family who would eventually
give the final judgement of William.
“Do you remember dealing
with a Mr. Harold Abbott?”
In his office, Mr. Easton has the
news broadcasting on the television,
where the anchor talks about the distribution
of John Kramer’s assets after his death,
and she mentions that most of them were in
real estate, which may lend more credibility
to the Nerve Gas House theory I mentioned
in the last episode of Things You Missed.
Also, the news station is WNKW News. If you
lived in North America around the heyday of
broadcast television, you may be familiar
with the 4-character station IDs given to
every television and radio station. All stations
east of the Mississippi River were required to
start with W. I’ve given plenty of evidence
that the setting of the Saw movies is on the
East Coast throughout this series, so this is
just one more factor in favor of that idea.
Another interesting aspect of his office is the
fish tank full of piranha, which as far as I know
are not a common pet, and are known for their
predatory behaviour. I think they’re symbolic
of this company.
“Piranha.” Good job John! You really know your fishies!
After William’s capture, he finds himself
in the Mr. Creepypasta Trap. Or maybe we
should just call it the preview of 2020 trap.
His opponent is the janitor, Hank, a smoker
who likely would not have been able to acquire
health insurance according to Umbella's policy.
“While only 52 years of age, this man
has continued to smoke even though he
has a history of high blood
pressure and heart disease.”
We eventually come to find out that
John chose Mr. Easton for his game,
because he once denied coverage for an
experimental cancer treatment. Hank is
the same age that John was when he died,
and I feel like he was chosen to make a
statement about the insurance company’s power
to, in a way, choose who lives and who dies.
Also, this is the first time John shows himself
on screen during the tapes where he explains
the rules to his victims, and I think he did
this to remind William of the face he once
encountered when two met at a party at Homeward
Bound Clinic. It didn’t matter that John was
giving away his identity in this one, because the
instructions for this game were delivered to Jill
in his will. In other words, The Trial of William
Easton could only take place after John’s death,
which I think is fitting, because it makes
William realize that the message that
Jigsaw is trying to convey, that because of his
policy, the blood is figuratively on his hands.
The trap asks its victims to use as little
oxygen as possible; whoever does that can
avoid being crushed by this machine. They’ve
both got the wrong idea here. In my experience
with scuba diving, the best way to conserve
air is to take slow, deep, continuous breaths.
William’s faith in his policy would
be challenged again in the next trap,
but first, there would be some interesting
details of note in the past of Jill Tuck.
After receiving the materials from John’s will,
Jill flashes back so some of the memorable
moments of her marriage and its downfall.
We see the grave of their unborn son Gideon,
which features an infinity icon, perhaps to
symbolize John’s belief in the idea of rebirth.
He considers his test subjects to be reborn
whenever they pass one of his traps. It’s not
entirely clear if the animals are connected to
this in a circle of life kind of way, or if they
could be connected to the location of his largest
game, which takes place at an abandoned zoo.
As far as horror movies in zoos
go… pretty good track record.
William Easton continues through his trial,
where he’s reminded of the party where he first
met John Kramer. It would appear that Amanda,
a former patient of the clinic, is also
present at this party wearing the same
outfit she had on during the reverse-bear
trap scene in Saw 1, minus those detached sleeves.
I guess Amanda doesn’t have that many
outfits, because in an earlier flashback,
she has the same shirt she had when she
helped John setup the bathroom game in Saw 3,
but you can tell by her hair that these
things aren’t taking place on the same day.
The next section of The Zoo Game took
place in what looks like a reptile habitat,
and I have to wonder if Kevin Gruetert saw that
one jump scare the year before in the Dark Knight…
Yeah, that one, and basically thought,
“you know what? We’re gonna do that too.”
Just doesn’t hit quite the same
though. But I do like this trap,
because it forces William to make similar
kind of life-or-death decisions to those
made in his work, but it personalizes them by
using his own employees. Does he kill a
family woman nearing the end of her life,
or the healthy young man with no family?
His insurance formula would have him
cover the man rather than the woman,
but in the heat of the moment,
that’s not what he decides.
“As you can see, the choice is not so clear when
you’re face to face with the people
whose blood will stain your hands.”
We revisit the moment William’s
policy personally affected John,
who had been seeking health coverage to
undergo an experimental gene therapy for
his cancer from an Norweigan doctor. He brings
in a pamphlet, where we can see the name of the
doctor is Sorin Popescu. That happens to be
the name of the first assistant art director,
whose name was also seen on the box in the FBI
headquarters in Saw 5. Since I always like to
make up stories so that these easter eggs
make sense in-universe, I’m gonna say that
Dr. Popescu was on vacation visiting the US,
where he happened to be the victim of a crime.
When John’s coverage is denied, he goes on a
rant about the empty promises of politicians
who claim that health-related decisions should
be made by doctors and patients. He motions to
the clip playing on the TV screen, which is a
quick shot of John McCain, who was a senator,
who ran for president in 2008. I’m not going
to pretend like I know anything about politics,
but from what I can gather,
this guy opposed Obama’s health
care plan which came out in 2009,
the same year Saw 6 was released.
Obviously the movie takes place in 2006
though, not long after Jigsaw’s death,
but I image that McCain already had
his views about health care beforehand,
so the meaning behind the clip is still relevant.
Room number three is the steam maze, where
William has to guide his lawyer through a
dangerous labyrinth filled with vapors hot
enough to leave a nasty burn. Come on man,
just climb over the railing a little bit and
pull the lever from an angle where you don’t
get burned. You ever played Crash Bandicoot?
These steam things can totally be avoided.
He also gets kicked in the balls
and is fine two seconds later,
but whatever. Let’s go back to the FBI storyline.
They’ve figured out that there is an
abnormality in Strahm's fingerprints,
which they found at the crime scene of the
opening trap. Special Agent Perez shows
Hoffman the screen with the analysis report,
where we see Strahm’s name above a few others.
Anthony Ianni is a new name for us,
he’s the production designer on this
movie. These other two names are not new.
They’re both first assistant art directors,
but in the world of the movie, Sean Scoffield
is an FBI Agent and possibly newspaper writer,
and Sorin… well, we just discussed Sorin,
the Norweigan doctor turned tourist crime
victim. Someone’s gotta make a Saw movie,
or at least a comic or something with all
these easter egg characters as the
main characters. Just for my sake.
As the game nears its end, Jill prepares
for her plan for its conclusion. And in
her apartment there are some photos of
her and John which seems to tell us the
reason she’s still willing to help him; if she
keeps those pictures up after their divorce,
it would seem that there are still some
feelings there. Also, how old were they
when they got married? I mean, the pictures
are out of focus in the background there,
but look at that hairline. The marriage
seems like it might be kind of recent.
The biggest room of The Zoo Game features
a large spiral both on the door and on the
carousel itself. The spiral has been a symbol
associated with both Jigsaw and Billy the Puppet
from the very beginning, which will presumably
be explored more in the ninth movie, Spiral.
To match Mr. Easton’s ratio where he rejects
two thirds of insurance applicants, Jigsaw
asks him to kill off two thirds of his application
review team. The trap resembles a carnival ride.
He uses Billy for the tape this time rather
than footage of himself, and with his white
face paint and cheeky bowtie, Billy kind of does
resemble a carny. Of all the Billy video tapes,
this one might be the creepiest. Not sure
what it is. The carnival music that comes
in when the ride starts moving provides great
contrast with the sheer horror of the scene;
it brings out the worst in each employee
because of their desperation to live. In the end,
Mr. Easton goes full iDubbbz and
simps his staff down to two women.
Meanwhile, the FBI has finished
descrambling the tape from the
Pendulum Trap seen in the last movie and
they invite Hoffman to see the results.
Detective Hoffman has no choice but to go with
Erickson and Perez to see the results of the
voice descramble. Now as an audio professional…
I don’t think that’s a thing you can do. The
Jigsaw voice is made by layering together audio
with various pitches. So the FBI could analyse
different frequencies, but they’d have no way
of knowing which one was the original voice.
Normally I don’t talk about mistakes and
just accept the fact that it's a movie,
but I mean, come on, this movie is directed
by an editor! He should have caught that.
But despite all of that, I think this is probably
actually my favorite scene in the Saw franchise,
and at the end of it, as Hoffman is going to his
car after taking out three agents, we see this
prop, which looks like one of those chattering
teeth gags. I don’t know why this would be here,
inside this computer lab if not to foreshadow the
upcoming scene. This is essentially someone’s jaw,
and I think it’s a sign that Hoffman’s jaw is
about to get damaged in the Reverse Bear Trap 2.0.
But before heading back to the zoo
for the last part of William’s trial,
Hoffman goes back into the lab,
🎵 Back to the lab again 🎵
where Special Agent Erickson is STILL
ALIVE, and covers him in gasoline.
BRUTAL! JUST BRUTAL!
“Brutality!”
When William makes it to the final room, he sees
his sister, Pamela, the Jigsaw reporter condemned
for her sensationalist writing. But his life
ends up in the hands of the family of Hank Abbot,
the man who died as a result of Umbrella Health
terminating his insurance plan on a technicality.
“One… Two… Three!”
BOOOOOMM
So far, this is the only Saw
movie to have a post-credit scene,
where we see Amanda circa Saw III
delivering a message to Corbett Denlon.
“Don’t trust the one who saves you.”
I’ve seen this scene criticized in the
past, because we never specifically see
what comes of it. In Saw 5, Corbett was
rescued by Hoffman and taken to safety,
and we never see her after that.
At least not that we know of.
So what was the meaning of this scene? I think
the implication here is that after saving Corbett,
she told Agent Perez that some woman warned
her not to trust the one that saves her. So
Perez was immediately suspicious of
Hoffman. This is reflected in this
line after Perez is badly injured
by the exploding Billy the Puppet.
“She said your name you know. Last thing she said
was Detective Hoffman. Why’d she
say that? Why’d she say your name?”
Then in Saw 6, Perez is revealed to have survived
the attack, but even after supposedly determining
that Strahm was the second accomplice, Perez
still doesn’t look too happy to see Hoffman.
I think it all goes back to Corbett’s warning.
I really don’t see how else they would have had
the idea to look back at what kind of knife
was used to cut Seth Baxter’s Jigsaw piece,
what kind of oil was left behind
by Strahm’s fingerprints or really
any reason to doubt that one of the tapes
was recorded by someone other than John.
At the beginning of this video I discussed
the recurrence of the number 6, because this
was the sixth movie. The original Saw saga was
released in consecutive years from 2004 to 2010,
ending with Saw 7. Technically Saw 3D, but I
call it Saw 7. That was originally going to be
the last movie, and so it was given an
alternate name: Saw: The Final Chapter.
Now in Saw 6, at the Umbrella Health company,
William Easton’s desk is where all contract
disputes come to an end. He even tells John,
when he comes in to plead his case about
getting coverage for the gene therapy…
“Well the buck stops here John. Fire away.”
So basically we’re being told that whatever it
is, it stops at Mr. Easton’s desk. And on Mr.
Easton’s desk at all times is these
dice, which add up to the number 7.
OK, big deal, there’s some dice,
they happen to add up to seven. There’s seven
movies. It’s probably a coincidence, right?
Well, I was going to say the same thing,
but then I realized that no matter what
angle, and no matter what scene in the movie,
the numbers facing the camera ALWAYS add up to
seven. Which means someone had to specifically
go in and move these dice every time the
camera moves in order to keep this consistent.
The buck stops here. And
the series stops at seven.
So make sure you join me for the
next episode of Things You Missed,
where I’m going to be covering the final
chapter of the initial yearly Saw movies:
Saw 7. Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for
new horrors every week, ring that deathbell
for notifications, and I’ll see you in
the next one. Assuming we both survive.
“Piranha.”
Yes. Very good John. Very good.